are you excited for injustice too well
we're still a couple months away from
the superhero fighting game but
NetherRealm Studios hasn't slowed down
when it comes to introducing new
characters the developer recently
revealed a bunch of fighters in a recent
trailer and I'm going to run you through
each and every one of them I'm Matt this
is a game spot news update and make sure
to LIKE and subscribe for up-to-date
news on injustice too so first off the
latest shattered alliances trailer shows
us a lot of characters we haven't seen
before and it's not immediately clear
who's going to be a character you can
play as it's safe to say that both Green
Lantern and green arrow are playable and
we already knew Bane was going to be in
the game too we even get our first look
at him in action sort of I mean we
really just see him get his ass kicked
by the two green superheroes on top of
all that we get glimpses at reverse
flash and Captain Cold but it's not
immediately clear if those two will be
playable nether realm included
non-playable characters in its mortal
kombat x story mode so that may be the
case here and also I couldn't imagine
injustice to having both flash and
reverse flash in the same game that just
doesn't make sense injustice two
releases for ps4 and xbox one on May
sixteenth we recently spoke to nether
realm about the fighting games gear
system how it works and if it'll upset
the balance and online matches you can
check that out on gamespot com but if
you want to watch some superhero action
check out our gamespot universe channel
where we cover all of your favorite
movies TV shows and comic books